في خبر اخر كشفت تقرير الاستثمار الاجنبي
المباشر لعام 2023 الصادر عن مؤسسه افد اي
انتيليجينس ان قطر احتلت المرتبه الاولى
لافضل الدول للاستثمار الاجنبي المباشر
عالميا خلال العام الماضي واشار تقرير الى
ان الهند احتلت المركز الثاني بينما حل
المغرب ثالثا وارجع التقرير السبب لتصنيف
قطر في المرتبه الاولى لماده من امكانات
اقتصاديه وفرص استثماريه كبرى تحفظوا على
الاستثمار الاجنبي المباشر واتوقع تقرير
ان تشهد الاقتصادات الكبرى في الشرق
الاوسط وشمالي افريقيا خلال العام الجديد
زياده في الاقبال هذا الاستثمارات ويعتمد
التقرير الذي يبحث الاستثمار الاجنبيه
المباشر لافضل 50 وجه على بيانات صندوق
النقد الدولي
والاسواق المختصه